El Nido is a very interesting place at night.
And I'm currently in the Lonesome Carabao Lounge.
I got it right?
And a carabao is like a,...
...how would you describe it, Marco?
You actually run the bar.
I do, yes.
A carabao is a water buffalo, Southeast Asian water buffalo.
It's the national animal of the Philippines.
I come here every two or three months.
I have a local manager to run the bar when I'm not here.
But yeah, we opened two years ago.
El Nido since then has been growing quickly.
But it's still an intimate place where...
...you know, you can have peace on the islands and fantastic nature.
But then at night, you've got, you know, places like this...
...and other places in town that has some good food and some good drinks.
Why El Nido?
Why did you choose El Nido?
Well I first came here three years ago just as a tourist...
...because I was looking for the frontier.
I wanted a place that was unspoiled,...
...beaches where you could be alone and not too commercialized.
And I found that in El Nido.
But I also felt it had potential to grow.
And every time that I've traveled,...
...I've always looked for a place where maybe I could buy some land...
...or settle down or something.
And this really seemed to be a promising spot.
Something that I could see taking off in the next five, ten years or something.